في حقل احيته امطار الشتاء بخضره السنابل
يتحدث ناصر وموسى عن تحول ياس جفاف العام
الماضي الى لهفه لمعانقه سنابل حصاد الصيف
المقبل الفلاح دائما هو متفائل ما دام
يحرس يزرع فهو متفائل ولكن كيتسنى
في هذه السنوات الاخيره ما بقاتش الامطار
كتنزل كيف ما كانت الحمد لله هذه الساعه
في هذه الساعه راه غدا مزيانه الا تكمل
الله بقى مره مره ويطيح المطار العهد
العام الحمد لله غير نسينا في العام اللي
فات يقتلع فتاح الله ومحمد الاعشاب الداره
في جوله صباحيه في حقل زرع فيه القمح
مستفيدين من عوده الامطار الغزيره التي
سجلت معدل 72 ملم مقارنه بثمانيه ثلاثين
ملم في السنه الماضيه هذه الارض
ودرنا فيها جلبانه ودرنا فيها الفول ولكن
الحمد لله
غالبيه الفلاحين المغاربه ياملون بحصاد
وفير هذا العام ليعوضهم ضعف محصول لعام
الماضي هذه الوضعيه هنا في المغرب فكيف هي
الوضعيه في تونس اما في تونس فقد امتلات
البحيرات والسدود وعادت الحياه الى
الانهار بعدما كانت اثرا بعد عين استبشر
المزارعون في وقت كانت السلطات تستعد
لاعلان حاله الطوارئ المائيه واعلان
الجفاف رسميا في البلاد
هكذا صارت في الاراضي الفلاحيه والزراعات
الكبرى في محافظه اريانا شمال العاصمه
التونسيه عادت اليها خدرتها وصارت حقولها
زرابي زاهيه الالوان بعد الامطار الاخيره
هناك يتفقد العم محسن حوله وكله استبشار
بموسم وفير المحاصيل بعدما كاد الياس يدب
الى قلبه فتره
يعني
اصابنا نوع من الياس لكن الحمد لله ربي
سبحانه وتعالى يعني جاتنا المطر
وبكميات هامه
بدل كل شيء
وبلغت ايرادات الامطار الاخيره حوالي 719
مليون متر مكعب تقريبا وفق احصاءات رسميه
وهو ما ساهم في امتلاء السدود بنسبه فاقه
الثلاثين بالمئه وضعيه تبشر بخير لكن
الحذر يبقى قائما اليوم تهني اقل مبدئيا
على الماء الصالح للشرف في تونس في الصيف
هذيا والحمد لله طبق القطاع الفلاحي متزال
مؤمل انا ان شاء الله ربي يغيثنا في
الاشهر في فيفا مارس يلزمنا برشا شويه
مضطر بزايد ولا بد من الاحتياط خاصه فيما
يخص القطاع الفلاحي ورغم تحسن الوضع
المائي في البلاد الا ان السلطات تعمل على
ايجاد حلول بديله من بينها مشاريع تحليه
مياه البحر ومد الانابيب واستغلال الاراضي
الصحراويه للزراعه وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس